حقيقه نعجز نقول قديش كان ممتع حقيقه
الشغل على هذه المقابلات وتقديمها لكم
ومثل ما كلكم بتعرفوا يعني قبل الهواء مع
الفنانين في تجهيزات فتعالوا اوريكم شويه
كواليس من تحضير المقابلات مع ضيوفنا
ايوه عليلي الصوت
ايوه الانسه
يلا احنا الان دقائق وحنكون معك على
الهواء قلبوا لي انا جالسين بيلعبوا لي
بيقلبوا لي الكاميرات بس ان شاء الله
دقائق حنكون معك على الهواء انا شايفتك
وشايفه الجمال وشايفه اللون الحلو وشايفه
الورد اللي وراك اللي ماشي مع اللبس
برهوم
برهوم على التليفون
اوه قاعد اكلم زوجاتي زوجاتك
انت تعمل لهم تعمل لهم فوان كول يعني
تجمعهم
زوم عشان نختصر
ط نفسك
احنا لايف السالفه طب احنا لو لعب ايش
حيصير حتكون مره متورط صح
والله لانه لايف بدخل بقاعد حسن مكاني
حسن مدير اعمالك طبعا ايش اخبارك الحمد
لله مين ساره ايوه بالظبط ساره كيف ياسمين
رفضتك كيف مهره رفضتك
كيف
العبره والنهايه
[موسيقى]
وحشتيني انت اللي وحشاني ايش الابداع هذا
المسلسل
رهيب دورك رهيب انت رهيبه
انا بحبك وانا قلبي حبيبتي والله طالعه
خرافيه احمد
الو هاي يا احمد
ازيك يا احمد انا بتفائل فيك كل رمضان
والله لانك
اكثر من اللي قبله هنكون معك على الهواء
حبيبتي
خلال دقائق فخليك معانا سمعاني يا ساره
اهلا يا خالد كيف حالك
الحمد لله تمام سامعاني كويس كل عام وانت
بالف خير يا رب
ربنا يخليك طب ميرسي سمعاني لان انا بتكلم
من الموبايل لاب توب حاسس حلو وكل الحكايه
على بعضها
لا لا لا الو
[ضحك]
الله
على الهواء ما اصدق
الرجوله كيف حالك
مش عايزه اضحك عشان سنتي طيب
يا سلام
لاحظت انك انت ما حنخرك كثير حنكون الان
معك على الهوا سريعين وحنرجعك للتصوير ان
شاء الله سريعا بشكركم جدا على
ابدا ابدا اصلا احمد ترى انت لسه مش على
الهواء انا وانت بنتكلم كده بس ديناميمه
تحت الهوا
يا حبيبتي كل سنه وحضرتك طيبه والله يا
ساره انا عملت جيمز
مجايبر مكانش عمل اللي انا عملته النهارده
عشان الحق جيت في 20 دقيقه من مدينه
الانتاج الاعلام والله طب ما انت ما تعملي
ما تعملي يا دكتوره مش حاعمل حرمت خلاص
حصل خير الحمد لله لحقتي هنا ولحقتي هنا
يلا المهم ان انا جيت يلا ايه بركه رمضان
الجميله ايمان ده كله يطلع منك يا ايمان
ده كله يطلع منه
وبتفرج على الثمن عندك في القالري عندنا
او في غرفه التحكم في واحد انت الكرش تبع
حياته وحب وعمره كله
فبيسلم عليك برضو بس رافض انه يعني يقول
اسمه صراحه وخلاص
فبده يكون فكره ادميرو ما بده كده يعبر لك
خلاص اهلا وسهلا بصفصف الملكه
سمعاني اهلا اهلا
دخلنا هواء ولا لسه يا قطه لا لسه لسه يا
ملكه
فايز يا فايز
اهلا بالشيخه ساره هلا هلا وغلا يا مرحبا
ومسهلا ومقربه احنا بس حبينا نسلم عليك
قبل الهواء ونتاكد انه كله تمام والان
خلال دقيقه حنقول على الهواء مباشره معاك
جهزينة
[موسيقى]